>>Dawn: Being able to departmentalize
really helps us integrate curriculum,
and provide opportunities for
students to apply and transfer
so we could really see mastery.
>>Anne: Departmentalization
is just the concept
of this teacher teaches this topic,
and this teacher teaches this topic.
The power of that is that a
teacher can really dig deep
into that particular content.
They could become an expert.
The integration piece of it is the
concept that we've paired Language Arts
and Social Studies and we've
paired Science and Math.
Intentionally we connect and
integrate those concepts together.
It's kind of the marriage between
departmentalization and integration.
>>Dawn: In fourth, fifth
and sixth grade,
we have two classrooms
at each grade level.
One teacher teaches Science and Math,
and one teacher teaches
Language Arts and Social Studies.
>>Lindsay: Last year, we moved the
teachers between classrooms and we found
that it was difficult to have all
of your materials on a cart ready
to go into the next classroom.
The students get to see now
a math-enriched classroom,
a reading enriched classroom, and
they're not overwhelmed with content
from all different areas, and
then just seeing a different face
in the day can capture
them in a different way.
>>Jon: I see all the
sixth graders every day.
Our block is
two-hours-and-fifteen-minutes,
and I focus on the Math and the science.
>>Laura: And I teach the
Social Studies and Literacy.
We've worked really hard on making
sure we have shared expectations
for the kids.
Some days there's this
defined reading time.
Other days, it's more of
a Social Studies concept
and we're using our literacy skills to
get to those understandings and ideas.
>>Laura: Social organization
is how you run your society.
>>Lexie: In Social Studies,
we've been playing a game based
on the Mayan culture.
>>Laura: It's kind of like, "We're doing
this great interactive thing, okay,
now let's do some research."
So they're doing some close
reading and seeing what corroborates
and what conflicts with
what they already know.
But the topic is the Maya.
>>Student: Folding paper
books are part of the...
>>Laura: Some of the time students
say, "Did we even do reading today?
>>Dawn: It's one thing to see
it in a guided reading group,
students accomplishing a task or a
skill, but to be able to make decisions
in Social Studies about how they're
using those skills is a whole other
level of understanding.
>>Anne: It's really the
power and the integration.
It's how we can apply what we're
learning in Math to what we're doing
in Science, and how that helps
us think like an engineer,
you know, or think like a scientist.
>>Jon: We're just connecting
what's going on in our parking lot,
and it's going to hopefully make us
think about gravity and how things flow.
>>Jon: What I always shoot
for is an integrated piece
where they're doing something science...
>>Jon: But imagine a laser...
>>Jon: But the backside is there's a
whole lot of math in what you're doing.
>>Jon: So that bathroom pass is
the same height off the floor
as that Apollo insignia,
is that correct?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Jon: And then all of a sudden,
math isn't a bad word anymore.
>>Jon: The same principle
is happening right here.
So we get to go ahead and
try it to see if it's right.
>>Jon: And let's go to Point A first.
>>Student: Yep.
>>Jon: Get a reading on that.
Remember, we're using tenths.
>>Jon: Why in the heck are we measuring
concrete that they poured this summer?
Why is that important?
>>Lexie: What happened was it rained
so much and there's a huge puddle all
around here, because the drain was
clogged, and the busses were having
to drive straight through
all the rainwater.
>>Laura: We are doing
a drainage analysis.
We're trying to see if
they did it correctly.
>>Constantine: We've been using a GPS
to find our longitude and latitude.
>>Laura: We started off
by finding our spots.
And using the transit to measure
the height of each of those.
>>Laura: Stand nice and still.
>>Student: 7 point 37 point 4.
>>Constantine: Then we measured
the distance from each of those
to the drain, which was Point B.
>>Jon: Finding out if the
slope in the drain is correct,
involves quite a bit of math.
A lot of computation, measurement.
We wanted to do something
that would tie into one
of our three big spheres of Science.
Hydrosphere is a perfect connection for
measuring the slope of the parking lot,
because it connects to watershed.
>>Lexie: If it's clogged, our
water's not going to go through to
where we want it to go, the
watershed is not going to work.
>>Jon: Okay!
Okay.
>>Jon: You couldn't ask
for a better laboratory.
>>Jon: So think about rocks, minerals,
weathering erosion, geosphere.
>>Jon: This is a way to get
them into the Hydrosphere
in a really practical meaningful way.
>>Lexie: It's a foot different.
>>Jon: It's a foot difference, so
what's cool about from that point
to this point, is water going to flow?
>>Lexie: Yeah.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Jon: It'd definitely flow.
>>Jon: It gives me a concrete foundation
to connect future learnings to.
>>Anne: Conceptual understanding is
at the core of what we are doing.
How do we look at units of study,
and not just looking at
isolated content areas.
>>Anne: What's happening in fifth grade?
>>Anne: I meet with every
team every week.
Grade level teams as well as vertical
teams to see how what we're working
on is having an impact on students.
>>Jon: Now all of a sudden,
we're doing decimals.
And then we had to figure out the
difference between two measurements.
>>Laura: I wonder if you
could tie that site analysis
into the fourth grade site analysis and
that grant we got, or we're getting.
>>Jon: Oh, that's perfect.
>>Jon: Rather than being an
expert at seven different things,
I can work really hard to become
an expert at two subjects.
>>Jon: Copy that, good work!
>>Jon: It's a wonderful way for me
to become the best teacher possible.
>>Dawn: The benefits with the
students have been phenomenal.
It's created more purposeful, more
authentic setting for learning,
and we've seen that every day.